a lady Gaga song goes for the
applause-plause he up on the step yeah
no he's not little buddy
let's get on the stack we did it hi I'm
Alison I'm constant as I play Adam and
this is animal time as for like Bible
and the time it takes this dog to lick
off the yogurt and then five things
rhyming with the time rhyme crime I want
to try I want to try rhyme crime sex
education characters okay honor
Adam Otis maybe in the time it takes
this dog to collapse name three Disney
songs a whole new worlds embarrass
that's the staple Disney song in the
time it takes this dog to steal a
sausage name three famous fans I forgot
everything in 1975 and the time it takes
this dog to ascend to the ceiling named
five table condiments what's a condiment
like salt and pepper ketchup vinegar and
so any good and the time it takes this
dog to abandon its stick name all things
you'd find in the garden a shovel a mud
of flowers you would also find a spade
and maybe that dog gave up very quickly
I do it he didn't you just saw at the
gate it was in the time it takes this
dog to climb one step named for
well-known pop song so this is a run
question for me and a lady Gaga song who
goes for the little buddy let's get on
step we did it well done any time it
takes this dog to squeeze through the
wall name for fast food chains
McDonald's subway wait there's more
I'd this work wait I don't know any I do
ya ready simple Donald in your time it
takes his part to wake up named fool
Netflix shows sex education The Witcher
back in you [ __ ] I think we're both
winners I think we're both the ones I'm
honest windows and that was animal
timers for that bottle thank you
[Music]